I'm going to quickly call together the
work section of the SB 296 subcommittee
and so we're going to be having the
pledge
shortly with when the full committee
comes so we'll we'll forgo The Pledge
right now in in favor of basically
having that for the for the full
committee and uh just kind of go
straight into it so we have I think a
couple of sessions where all of us
learned a lot I know that I did
and I think we were all in a position
uh at the end where we were comfortable
with um the fact that the
original bill as submitted was not going
to be a bigger burden on the commission
uh than it already has in front of it so
you know with that going forward what I
would like to do is recommend to the
full committee
that um
we're looking to go forward with
recommended for future legislation
um with some of the uh the follow-up
items that we we kind of talked about we
talked about
um you know the concern with the
caseload
um and we talked about
um
the fact that uh their rules need to be
with that I I pretty much submitted the
the bulk of what I have to say to the
to the bulk of a subcommittee
um
I did get an email from Jay Henry who is
uh the director of performance audits
for the state and he did say that um the
lpaoc is going to meet on November the
10th
he didn't specify exactly what time you
have to work a couple times he threw out
and uh location but once that's kind of
firmed up it's my intention to go and
speak before the lpaoc to say that the
subcommittee and hopefully we can
convince the full committee
um would would like to have a
performance audit and representative
Smith has
indicated an interest in you know
participating so if anybody else was
interested in doing so I do think it
would add weight
um I know that there's probably a lot of
areas that are going to be in
competition and there's only so much
room that uh that they have to navigate
so anything that we could do to kind of
strengthen the case
um I would certainly appreciate uh but
beyond that
I did get some minor Corrections uh from
Jen
for relative to uh some of the the
formatting and the only substantive
change that she made is in in my
original
blurb
uh what did I say rules rules would be
uh brought up to date
um
so she she added to that um uh rules
brought up to date and approved by the
joint legislative committee on
administrative rules so
um that was just a minor addition that
that she made to uh
to what I wrote
so
basically just where and that bottom
paragraph which says that the rules we
brought up to date
and she's adding the words and approved
by the joint legislative committee on
administrative rules okay
so
um that's basically where we're at does
anybody have any thoughts or concerns on
that before we go to the full committee
well
this was short and sweet then short and
sweet you have a question or would you
like in motion to
to support or approve your maybe report
uh that would be I would prefer a motion
to support it yes would you be would you
be interested in making such emotion I
would be pleased to make a motion that
we
I guess adopt as a as a result of our
committee efforts that we adopt the
committee report
okay that might be happy to accept all
right
yes I'll I'd be happy to speak to that
and and and just because I didn't have
my mic on before I say that I'd make the
motion to a doctor committee report
okay and the
I have to say that
the
the committee which was well led by its
chair
and much appreciated
I think provided lots of information to
us with regard to the Human Rights
Commission
and
I'm absolutely convinced that changes
need to be made to make the Human Rights
Commission more responsive to the people
of the state
and that the current system as it is
established in in large part established
by Statute
but as it's being implemented just is
taking too long
and it just is not workable and I don't
think it can can continue to work in the
manner in which it is and I recognize
that the director and other people at
the commission are attempting to make
change
uh within that and within those
parameters but
I don't think that we can wait for
a long period of time and first of all
not sure that the changes that have been
talked about really are going to bring
about the type of success with
we would like to see happen out there
but
I
just not convinced that the current
system works can work for the people of
the state and would hopefully in the
future
see major improvements and changes made
Beyond
what we're coming out within our report
today
well I mean I I think I agree that we
all had some major concerns
having kind of sat through the reporting
on on the uh parole board and and the
amount of depth that they went into my
hope really is that having a performance
audit will get into a lot of the depths
that that we just weren't able to do I
mean what we were able to do was really
uncover a lot of problems but I still
don't think at the end of the day we
were able to drive to all the solutions
um and so I'm really hoping and that
we're successful with with the
application for the lpaoc
representative Smith
thank you Mr chair
um
I I feel
confident in being able to speak for
every member of this subcommittee
that we became aware
of
circumstances that
through no particular fault of anyone
um result in
unconscionable
circumstances faced by people who have
gone to a state agency to ask for help
to wait two years three years four years
before there's resolution is
not acceptable it's wrong
um
to have a clear uh
expression by the leadership
of the commission that they don't have
the resources they need to carry out
the law and the rules as they are
required to
um
that is pretty serious they find
themselves in a position where they feel
they have to I guess play the hand that
they've been dealt
um and uh
trying to make the best of it
the one example that stands out is by
coming into us and telling us that they
knew that the backlog was terrible and
the caseload was terrible and they've
been able to cut that in half and when
we asked how did you get more money did
you get more stuff no they just took
half of the complaints and put them on
the back burner
um and that's
not something that anybody should be
expected to do or anybody take pride in
and we as the legislature have an
obligation to make sure that people who
think we have in place a system
to make sure that we do in fact have a
system to help them so the work that was
done under the chairs
leadership is very very important and
the report
um
is worded I think skillfully
and carefully
um not to gloss things over but also not
to
[Music]
um
to resist the temptation for Vendetta
all right well let's uh olaj during this
meeting then and I will see everybody
but we should vote oh we vote for the uh
for the motion to accept the report
access
yeah
find a motion to accept a report on uh
Senate Bill 296 all in favor say aye
aye vote
to unanimous five to zero vote thank you
thank you representative wolfer for
reminding me of our realities
um
so okay so with that we're adjourned and
we'll see everybody back at 1 30 for the
okay
the college meeting of the house
Judiciary Committee to order and we'll
Begin by pledging Allegiance and
representative Andrus would you like to
allegiance of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands
for all
things
thank you
and Mr first of all it's just nice to
see everybody again
and Mr clerk would you like to call the
roll
thank you Mr chairman uh representative
I'm going to do this just write down
Johnson
uh representative Andrus
representative Birch
substitute
chairman you
for representative
critical
this is going to be fun
representative De Lorenzo
representative Gordon here oh no excuse
me
all right wait a minute
oh
so representative questions here from
this representative Kenny
okay so far so we're making progress now
what if you were me you wouldn't be on
office
I'm gonna find you on this okay go
back this way uh representative Oregon
here
representative Kelly
representative Kenny is actually
representative wrong
oh no
it doesn't matter but believe me nobody
knows what happens to this piece of
paper
and now I have corrected that in all
representative Langley here
representative Macbeth representative
McQueen here representative murder
representative anoner I already called
representative page
representative Simpson
representative emergency Smith here
representative Sylvia representative
trottier
going once
going twice
not here
huh no he's there
well where's it
and representative welper is here
in fact we have what 18 19 Opticon thank
you Mr President
thank you Mr Clerk
we have uh today our purpose of our
meeting today is to vote on
reports on our retained bills we have
eight retained bills I did send around a
our interim study bills and I did send
around a list of those bills and the
reports that were published the
committee reports that came out in our
calendar
I would say that we
already had a meeting on this back on
June 8th there was a minority the
committee that did attend that day but
we did go through the eight interim
study bills
five of the bills we indicated that we
thought were fairly easily disposed of
with recommendations
one bill we decided to create a study
committee which we'll hear about later
and two bills we felt that it was
necessary that we made no couldn't come
up with a recommendation on and felt
that it was better to have the full
committee act on those
I did
um prepare some committee reports on the
bills that we did act on that day but we
didn't have a majority of the committee
that day and I think we still need to
have the full committee vote on those
bills
and what we'll do is we'll go through
the bills in order
uh in by order number by on the sheet
that you see here
and we'll begin with House Bill
124 and what I'll do is try to give you
a little bit of tell you what the
committee did when we met back on June
8th and then you can decide what you
would like to do today
I don't think we need to have a lot of
discussion today on these bills
[Music]
and because we have the committee's
already had a lot of discussion on these
bills uh when we heard them uh the first
time
and so I don't think we need a lot of
discussion but
um I'll entertain uh
entertain what conversation I think we
need to have in order to make our
recommendations as required
so the first bill is House Bill 124
adopting the uniform real property
and when the committee met back on June
8th the committee voted unanimously to
recommend for further legislation
the right now there is a uh the real
estate probate practitioners are
putting together a a revised proposal
and I have an email which I just
received
from Elise salic and if you remember
Elise salik was the attorney who spoke
and I think pointed out many of the
flaws in The Proposal that we had before
us
uh that day and she says I'm emailing
you to update the status on it on a new
proposed transfer on death statute
we have drafted a totally new statute
based on the uniform act and our
drafting group met today to review that
initial draft we've divided the statute
into manageable sections each of which
will be reviewed and edited by our
committee
this is a complicated statute and we
need to carefully consider how deeds
will be created and how our new statute
will tie into our existing probate laws
and our existing real estate conveyance
statute and our disclaimer statute and
our durable power of attorney statute
we'll be meeting again toward the end of
October to share our revisions
and we are working diligently on the
statute
so
and I responded to that by saying that
we needed to have that done by November
1st so that it could be brought forward
as a statute
so with that I guess
we had previously recommended it or the
small committee had recommended it for
further legislation
and I don't know if other people have
representative Smith
thank you I do have a a little question
um
about your comment Mr chair when you
said you told her that you needed to
have something by November 1st to
um
I don't see that by November 1st we have
to make a recommendation but we don't
have to write
an LSR we don't have to have language so
that
um that November 1st is only for us not
not for her it would be after that but I
think that if I remember correctly
that the conversation that took place
around this and then the Senate bill
that we will also hear
um that they're very similar
um in the Senate Bill there was also an
amendment suggested I Believe by Senator
quote about
um
making sure that no one was forced to
become a beneficiary against their
choice so that I think what we agreed to
was that
um
we supported the concept but did think
that the language to be considered by
the next legislature would have to
address a number of concerns including
but not limited to the uh
the opportunity for the beneficiary to
I think that's correct and the reason I
said November 1st wasn't for us to do
our recommendation I think the
reason I said that is because the filing
period I believe starts on November 9th
and so if we wanted to be able to file
legislation for next year it had to be
Timely
I'll make a motion I recommend for
and move by representative McLean
seconded by representative nodder that
we recommend
are you ready to vote
I see lots of heads nodding
and Mr clerk uh would you like to take a
role
I would
uh on the motion of recommending for
future legislation house bill 124.
representative McLean
yes
representative Sylvia Park quotes yes
representative Johnson yes
representative noidder yes
representative murder yes
representative Kelly yeah
representative Andrus yes representative
Smith yes representative wrong
yes representative Horrigan yes
representative diorenzo yes
representative Chase yes representative
Christian
representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes representative
Simpson yes representative Gordon yes
that makes it unanimous should be 19
right
19 to zero
19 in the affirmative zero in the
negative
thank you
Mr chair yes could you refresh my fading
memory about the procedure we've taken a
vote do we have a blurb okay I don't
know a report that gets submitted also
or is there no report for this there is
a report and the reports will appear in
the calendar
thank you and with the report then
indicate that while we're recommending
this for further
legislation we believe that there
are ways that the bill must be improved
yes thank you in fact I already
that's why I made The Campaign which
would which I would be glad to uh to
read to you and I said the bill clearly
has Merit for people who wish to pass
property onto others without the
formality of probate Administration or
the creation of a trust however the
initial bill lack protections against
fraud and undue influence therefore the
committee decided that it needed more
work but State planning practitioners
have been working with the committee to
revise a proposal which will be
foreign
the next bill was House Bill 248
relative to the judicial retirement plan
and when we met back on June 8th the
committee at that time voted unanimously
not to recommend for further legislation
and just by way of
background
it
when it was presented to us it was
presented to us by representative Lynn
at the for at the first instance and
indicated that they needed to do an
amortization study
to determine what the effect was because
I think the intention was that it could
end up costing the state less if we
changed the plan so that judges had to
work longer in order to obtain their
pension and that the pension benefits
would not be as rich as they currently
are for judges and I shouldn't say rich
as lucrative and so
they uh they did the amortization study
and I think the result was the
amortization study showed that basically
there wouldn't be if they changed the
plan there wouldn't be that much of a
substantial savings so to the state and
any savings that would occur would be
over a extremely long period of time
so I don't think there was any
continuing interest in in pursuing the
bill
representative Smith I I have it in
front of me I should know the answer to
this um that language wasn't retroactive
was it
no it was not retroactive it would apply
sir
any discussion of motion
representative Smith
Mr chair I move that we not recommend
um House Bill 248 for further
legislation
second
moved by representative Smith seconded
by representative wolper that we
not recommend House Bill 248 for future
legislation
any other discussion seeing none
representative wolper Mr clerk would you
I'm not recommending House Bill 248 for
future legislation
representative McQueen yes
the court votes yes representative
Johnson
yes representative green
representative norter yes representative
murder yes representative Kelly
representative Andrus yes
representative Smith yes representative
wrong yes representative Morgan yes
representative Lorenzo yes
representative Chase yes representative
Christian yes representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes representative
Simpson yes Mr chairman yes I have it 19
in the affirmative zero in the negative
and
I do
have a report would you like me to read
it I do yeah
I I indicate in the report that it's not
recommended for future legislation that
the bill would revise the calculation of
retirement benefits for judges under the
judicial retirement plan it would have
increased the time the judges are
required to serve in order to obtain
full retirement benefits
the intent would be to reduce the
contribution to be made to the plan by
the court system after completing an
amortization study there did not appear
to be a substantial Financial benefit
and no further effort need be made to
if that's okay with everybody
House Bill 379 relative to electronic
notice
again at our meeting on June 8th we
voted to not recommend for for the
legislation
uh
and
basically it comes down to the idea of
whether or not you want to change to do
away with having
uh newspaper publication and substitute
it with basically web publication
this would have allowed
cities towns political subdivisions to
do away with newspaper publication for
any
thoughts representative Horrigan
um
yes I think I think the newspapers still
have a role role in this there are
there are still like some people who
don't use the internet who still
subscribe to the internet and then
there's also like uh some stubborn old
people like me who insist on still
subscribing to the newspaper even though
it's getting smaller and smaller I read
the union leader this morning it took me
about five minutes and the Public
Notices were really like the most
interesting thing in the whole like
whole paper but that's uh
and also a good thing about the paper is
every copy is every copy is definitely
the same you can save the newspaper if
there's something of specific
if you're particularly interested in the
case and then also there are libraries
and there's newspapers.com which archive
these things so you have a reliable
record what the notice actually said and
I'd be worried if it was all electronic
then the older messages would kind of
disappear into the uh into the into the
ether as it were like in the hey I could
easily also Imagine in some cases where
there might be a dispute over what it
was to notice actually said in the first
place but if we have it in the newspaper
you know we can you can dig up the old
newspaper somewhere and see exactly like
what it was it said and then I don't
mind subsidizing the uh subsidizing
newspapers I said that's pretty much the
only thing interesting thing that's left
in a lot of these local papers um some
so so I agree with the commission's uh
recommendation to not recommend it for
did you want to make that emotion oh I
can make the motion if you want me to
appears
so I moved do we not recommend it for
and moved by representative Horrigan
seconded by representative chase that
we make House Bill 379 not recommended
is there any other discussion
and I'll represent vandros you felt
yeah I feel very strongly about it
because there are many uh which I'm in
the same group older people
who do not use the internet and they
find other ways to find the information
they want and even though newspapers are
getting smaller and smaller many people
still subscribe to them and that's how
they get their information and
until everybody has computers and
websites etc etc I uh I'm totally
on the motion of not recommending
Hospital 379 for future legislation
representative McLean
yes representative Sylvia
representative will Provo TS
representative Johnson yes
representative norter yes representative
murder yes representative Kelly
representative Andrus yes representative
Smith yes representative wrong yes
representative Horrigan yes
representative Dino Renzo yes
representative Chase yes representative
parishion yes representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes representative
Simpson yes Mr chairman yes once again
we have 19 in the affirmative zero in
the negative
but we've adopted
we've adopted the recommendation of not
recommended for future legislation for
when does it report to
or we've already prepared
um actually I have a report which I've
no the I did reports for the ones that
we addressed back on June 8th so there
were five
that the Comm the committee the members
who met on June 8th recommended and so I
did a report on each of those five just
to save us time
and to save everybody else from having
to write them
and then and I've also uh included a the
report which representative McLean has
already done on his his so they're only
going to be two reports that need to be
done and then we're going to figure out
who has to do those today
but the the report that I do have for
379 is the bill defines electronic
notice and authorizes electronic notice
in lieu of newspaper notifications and
statutes that require a city town or
other political subdivision to provide
notice of a meeting hearing or other
event
as print media evolves into more
web-centered formats it may eventually
become outdated however many of our
constituents do not have access or to or
utilize web services daily in time we
may be able to transition to this type
of format but the committee believes
that we need to include all citizens who
want to keep informed of the activities
of their government boards
that looks okay to everybody
okay and the next bill is a bill for
which we made no recommendation at the
at the last uh meeting and that's House
Bill 1181 allowing the biological father
of an unborn child to petition the court
for an injunction prohibiting the
biological mother from having an
abortion
and
thank you Mr chairman I would like to
move that we um
do not recommend that this bill
um be considered for further legislation
is there a second to that
who's second the representative Chase
um
yep yes I would be happy
um to make uh this discussion
uh
there actually has been some water
either under the bridge or over the dams
since
um we met in June
um
relating to issues of Reproductive
Rights
um but nonetheless the core principles
continue and that is
um the uh
the right of a woman
to control
to make decisions concerning her own
body
I say that recognizing that there is not
a uniformity of opinion
and I understand that and uh give full
Credence to the Views that other people
have
but New Hampshire is a state that for
most of its years
has adopted the libertarian the classic
libertarian philosophy that government
does not belong
um in um
and its citizens private lives and this
is one more example where the person
most
Central to the issue shouldn't be able
to decide who to consult who to involve
who to help make decisions that affect
her life and her future and
um
and she might very well choose to have
her
her partner her spouse perhaps if it is
in fact a spouse her religious leader
and certainly her
um medical provider involved but I don't
think there's room for 424 legislators
in the decision and so that is why I
believe it's not ready for
I
I know that this is a bill which
generates uh strong opinions but I know
that we debated this bill
uh quite a bit already and in our
committee I don't know that we need to
have a lot of debate here today if
you're willing to vote on the motion
okay
would you like to speak I would like to
speak okay you have a right to speak
and thank you Mr chairman and I concur
we have discussed this at once there was
a significant division of at least in my
mind in the community before and which
is why it's here for interim study
the representative from Durham this is a
bill about the government not being
involved that's the point of it is to
allow
the father
who is
one of the two parents
to have some say
in the life of the child
and the bill before us as it was written
recognize that the mother's rights were
preeminent
and the father's rights would be
subservient
but that the father should have rights
and I say why wouldn't the Father the
father should have the same I don't know
reproductive Freedom if you want to come
with that that's the month
so I will be voting that we should
recommend it
and that's as far as I need to go with
that
okay
okay Mr clerk would you mind calling the
role this is on the motion uh to
recommend not recommend for future
legislation how's
Bill 1181. yes that's fine it was the
motion was made by representative Smith
seconded by representative Langley
foreign
spell 1181 for future legislation
representative McQueen no
representative Sylvia
the clerk votes no
representative Johnson no
foreign
a bill anyway so I'll go ahead and vote
Yes
no
representative Kelly
representative Andrus no
representative Smith
yes
representative wrong yes representative
Horrigan yes representative diorenzo yes
representative Chase yes representative
parishion yes representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes representative
Simpson yes Mr chairman yes
that should make it 12 uh
two three four five six seven we should
make it twelve to seven twelve in the
representative Smith will you do the
report
I'd be honored to Mr chairman no
house bill yeah so we've voted
12 to 7 to recommend no
do not recommend future legislation for
house bill 1181.
House Bill 1389 establishing a superior
court
land use review docket again when the
committee met
last
June it made no recommendation
waiting for the full committee to make a
recommendation
I understand that the from
attorney had that the court system has
put in money in its proposed budget for
the next biennium for the land use
docket
yes I'd like to make the recommendation
that we not recommend it for further
legislation
and would you like to address your
motion
foreign
I think that um we've you know we've had
the just the land use board and appeals
board in um which was a different change
affected land use law in in action now
for two years and it's working pretty
well as far as uh expeding up the land
use docket I also feel like
um to
um
to to carve off this section might make
and not a you know may start
um if it's they're just delegated to one
judge there may be some bias that gets
it reinforced in that over the years
um and I also think the testimony um
there really was some um this was not
really clearly needed or desired by the
practitioners or the court so I I'd like
to just um wait on this for a little
while
any other discussion representative
McLean
thank you Mr chair
um it is my understanding that um the
while the court did not testify in favor
of it at the time they did come back to
us after and say yeah this is something
actually that they would be in favor of
and in fact as you mentioned that they
were looking to put money in and and the
reason for that is because they see a
lot of inconsistency with respect to uh
how the law is being applied so the
towns would still have the same
flexibility to make their own you know
bylaws and rules it's just that how it's
applied in the courts the hope with this
is that you're going to just have more
consistency with respect to the decision
representative Smith Mr chair would it
be permissible to you and the committee
if we ask
um
Mr head to answer a couple of questions
I'd rather not okay then could I just
um make a couple of points where I won't
have the opportunity to validate the
um the accuracy if I could please
um I'd be curious if I were permitted to
ask
um uh
if
the uh the courts increased the bottom
line of the request to the governor
um
or if they took money from some other uh
other purpose to apply it for this that
would be my first question that I would
ask my second question would be how
close is the court
to having a full complement of judges in
all the requisite Court levels
um so that it would not be required to
take a judge from another purpose to use
for this purpose
and my third question would be would it
not make more sense for the court to
have an effective
training program
for its judges so that the
inconsistencies are no more than the
inconsistencies that you would have when
reasonable people differ on on certain
outcomes but nonetheless the decisions
would be based on the law and
regulations as they are all of those
reasons cause me to think that um and
due course this might make sense but
um I do not I do not have the
verification that I would want to know
that in fact the judicial branch is is
other discussion
representative Horgan
um yes thank you if this if we
if we had passed this bill and signed
into the law it would have taken effect
January 1st 2023 and then about five
five and a half months or so after that
we would have passed a new new budget so
it would have been effectively
meaningless because one of the topics
which is included in every now I can't
remember whether this is I guess things
is an hb2 the trailer build in any case
every budget
always there's always a debate over the
number of Superior Court Justices we
should have so essentially we'd be
adding one but there's no guarantee we
wouldn't be taking one away
um immediately afterwards in fact we
probably wouldn't even have been able to
like
hire the person and confirm them before
like the budget process was done so I
think um
I think a standalone bill is unnecessary
and certainly absolutely
but it's not at all a surprise discover
that this is already going to be an
issue in the next budget because it it's
always an issue in the next budget and
certainly the
basic uh basic concept um is is an
interesting one but you know the next
finance committee will be dealing with
that so I don't think there's any need
any need for us to make any
recommendation uh now so I agree with
the not to recommend for future
legislation motion um
given that I know there's a bill which
will have this along with many other
issues uh coming down pretty soon and
if if we're if I'm lucky enough to be
re-elected I'm sure I'll be able to vote
on that and I'm sure I'm sure we we all
feel the same way thanks
I I have to say that I'm torn on it I
think the
the issue for me is do I think it would
be good to have a uh a a a court with a
land use docket and the answer to that
is yeah I do and I do because
um one of the advantages of having every
every every lawyer knows that when you
go to court if you know the judge you
can you have an expectation you
generally know have a sense of how a
judge is going to rule and it makes the
law much more predictable and practical
and
and if you focus on land use you can
make the time frames because one of the
big problems with land use cases right
now is they take forever and it
discourages everybody from being
involved if you want to contest a zoning
board decision or if you're a developer
and you want to put in a development and
so I think the land use docket has the
the the the other side of it so I
I think generally yes I would look for
future legislation to have a land use
board it makes sense to me but
the issue I have right now is the status
of the courts because the courts aren't
operating very effectively right now in
terms of their time frames and getting
things done and the backups in the court
and saying well geez do you want to
create a new program when the Court's
backed up and doesn't make that doesn't
make sense to me but so I think I'm
gonna
without any offense I think I'm going to
oppose the because I think it's a good
idea for the legislation I'm just not
sure how practical it is and
you Mr clerk you want to call a role
and the motion is no to recommend no
further legislation
um
house bill 1389. on the motion of not
recommending Hospital 1389
for future legislation representative
McLean
no
representative Sylvia
workbooks yes representative Johnson
no
representative daughter
representative murder no
representative Andrus yes
representative Smith
representative wrong yes
representative Horrigan yes
representative Lorenzo yes
representative Chase yes representative
parishion yes representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative Hayes yes representative
Simpson yes
uh Mr chairman no
one two three four makes it 14 in the
I was going to I I think I'm going to
vote in favor of
of further legislation
against
Okay so
we've voted 14 to five to recommend no
who would like to do a report on House
Bill
1389.
yes I will I would be happy to write the
report when can you get that to me I
promise when do you want it today yeah
that would be great okay today
okay
thank you
and relative to the right of a victim of
domestic violence to have a support
person present when testifying or being
deposed
and
when we did meet on June 8th we did have
uh the the members that day voted uh
unanimously to recommend no further
um
and
I guess I'll open it up for discussion
or for a motion
yes representative otter thank you Mr
chair I wasn't here that day I don't
remember why but I I liked this bill and
I thought it had a lot of Merit I spent
time this morning going through the
emails that we we got in support of the
bill with with recommended changes and
then I see somebody provided us all with
with a copy of that so I would be happy
okay is there a second to that
second represented by uh representative
uh moved by representative nodder that
we recommend future legislation seconded
by representative wolper
and any other discussion
representative nodder do you want to
speak to it even further
no we can we can vote on it
Macbeth
so um I just I'm going to say I think
that this issue is important
um I think that the the commission the
domestic violence commission is doing a
lot of good work and I understand that
they're reviewing all the protocols
regarding domestic violence so I'm
respectfully not going to support this
bill because I think there's going to be
recommendations that are going to come
in
um that that really are going to focus
yeah representative wolper thank you Mr
chairman
if we're going to have future
legislation and we know it because it's
such an important issue why wouldn't we
just recommend for future legislation
well I think the issue
in fact you could vote for future
legislation for any subject matter but
I think the question was whether or not
you would recommend this bill for future
legislation so and I think that's what
the concern and the concern that I had
with the bill and that is if you read
the bill literally
it requires this as a support person to
be provided for any party
which means
Not only would you be providing
representation for victims you could be
providing represent you'd be providing a
um
I don't think that that was certainly
the intention but I think that's the way
the bill is written the one thing it
says is that you can't the one thing
that bill says is that the it absolutely
says the judge cannot control the
support person can has no authority over
the support person
so the support person could get up and
rant and Rave in the court and the judge
can't do anything about it
uh the court person could swear in the
court can't do anything about it the
can I get engage and be noisy disruptive
argue with the other party
judge can't do anything about it the way
the current bill is written then that
doesn't make any sense
the other
it raises some other issues you uh with
regard to
um
the Intensive part was and I think there
was testimony that the support person be
able to go up on the stand while a
person is testifying
um
how does that prejudice a jury
does it Prejudice a jury
uh I think that's a that that's an issue
to wrestle with you know we we had a
bill about allowing people to have dogs
up there we didn't want dogs up there
because it would Prejudice the jury
uh so you're going to allow a support
person up there to do that I
um
so I just
uh with all respected representative gay
who I know is doing it absolutely uh
what she believes is the right thing I
can't I just don't I just don't see this
bill as being workable and the domestic
and I'll go one one other thing I'd like
to say about it is
the that we do have the domestic
violence task force they already came
out with one report
and we do Supply support persons right
now through the local agencies
and but when they came out with the task
force they said what people people what
people really need in domestic violence
cases is not a support person
what they need is a voice
what they need is attorneys only 13
percent of the people who appear
as as plaintiffs in domestic violence
cases are represented by an attorney
defendants are more likely to be
represented by attorneys
many of these people are intimidated by
the court system
they don't know what to say there is a
legal standard that you have to prove
you have to show that they've engaged in
Behavior which is effectively a criminal
act
um they don't know what to say they
don't know what to do and what they
really need is a voice what they really
need is somebody to speak on their
behalf in many cases and so long of the
short is I
I I can't support the bill because I the
way it's written I just don't think it's
workable at all in fact I think it's
harmful
um and yes it could be modified but just
to say well you know we could we could
come up with a better plan for domestic
violence I think that's true but I think
Coalition thought the Coalition but the
domestic Governor's domestic violence
task force could do that
that's a long show that's it so just to
I I agree with that and um
representative gay I want to say you
know I have worked for 15 years with
with Haven on the Seacoast and
representing women in their final
domestic violence restraining orders and
also in my family practice I work some
but
um the issue is a lot of times the
victim it's not only the defendant that
she's getting able to get the temporary
restraining about it's a dynamic within
the family and if you have an untrained
someone that's untrained supporting them
it might be someone that's part of that
system an example of a family member
that needs housing and so they're
they're supporting that purse that
victim but really they also have um you
know just she's worried about my kids
going to lose housing orders my son
going to lose housing you know or my
adult adult people so I think it's
dangerous um and I've seen it when you
have an untrained Advocate you know
luckily in Rockingham County a lot most
every of our you know anyone that
contacts Havens does get an advocate and
I support advocates so when you ask me
where's and why not support this because
I do see it very destructive to have
somebody that is not trained and the
court can't control because that's going
to reflect badly so I do I think the
attorney reference legal representation
is critical
um a you know Advocate that's trained in
trauma is critical but I think other
people is well-meaning as this bill is
would be very destructive
okay
and I guess you could call the roll
I thought you were going to speak no no
no okay
uh 1435 right
the motion was recommended right or
the the motion is
going to recommend
so on the motion to recommend
HP 1435 for future legislation
representative McLean no
representative Sylvia
work votes yes representative Johnson
no
representative norter
yes
representative murder no
representative Kelly
representative Andrus no representative
Smith
representative wrong yes
representative Horrigan uh no
representative Dino Renzo no
representative Chase no
representative Christian
no
representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth no representative
page no
representative Simpson
no
Mr chairman
I have it as one two three five in the
affirmative
I have myself representative NADA
representative wrong
that would be only four one two three
four okay so I have four in the
affirmative
did you have
oh Langley two three yes representative
and representative welper and daughter
and then
I would move to not recommend for future
electricity
I'd make the motion of to not recommend
for future legislation seconded by
representative Macbeth
clerk are you ready to call her role I
okay uh let's see if I can do this I'll
try it this way
on the motion of not recommending
Hospital 1435 for future legislation
representative McLean yes representative
Sylvia yes
Court votes no representative uh Johnson
yes
representative daughter no
representative murder yes representative
Kelly yeah
representative
bronze
no
yes
representative Ron no
representative Oregon yes representative
yes
representative Chase yes representative
representative Langley
representative Macbeth
yes
representative page yes representative
yes yes which is 15 in the affirmative
so we'll adopt a recommendation of not
recommended for future legislation
Senate Bill 243 permitting transfer of
death on Deeds for real property this is
a bill which is
nearly identical to the first bill that
make a motion to recommend for future
legislation
move by
representative McLean and
seconded by
any discussion
seeing none Mr Clerk
just to keep you busy you like to call
the roll this is on a motion of
recommend for future legislation for
it's not recommended right it's
recommended recommend for future
foreign
of recommending Senate Bill 243 for
future legislation representative McLean
yes
representative Sylvia
work votes yes representative
Johnson
yes
representative norter yes representative
Marner yes representative Kelly
representative Andrus yes
representative Smith yes representative
representative Horrigan yes
representative De Lorenzo yes
representative Chase yes representative
representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes representative
Simpson yes Mr chairman yes
my head oh it's not the right part they
have a 19 in the affirmative zero in the
negative
to recommend for future legislation
Senate bill 243.
our last bill which is Senate Bill 296
relative to complaint procedures and
cases before the commission for human
rights this is in fact a
Bill where we had a subcommittee and uh
caught up on the chair of the sub
committee to make a motion if he wishes
to do so yeah Mr chair I would make a
motion that we recommend for future
legislation
moved by representative McLean future
legislation and that subject
seconded by representative nodder
do you like to address your emotion
yes thank you Mr chair so
um the original Bill SB 296 as it was
presented to the committee uh basically
what it did is it eliminated the right
of the respondent
um to remove uh the case being brought
before the Human Rights Commission to
the Superior Court after finding a
probable cause and so um the the intent
of the bill was basically the claimant
has gone all the way you know to the to
the five yard line and at which point
the whole game gets moved to to a
different stadium and so when we looked
at it actually
48 states do not allow the removing by
the respondent to the Superior Court
there's only two states of which New
Hampshire is one and
um
our law that allows that removal was
basically modeled after a Massachusetts
law which the Supreme Court found to be
unconstitutional because the claimant
has the the the burden of proof the the
heavier burden of proof in the case
um they're the ones that get to to
choose the Forum and so
um from a constitutional legal
perspective everything about SB 296 was
okay it's fully constitutional
everything was good there the the
concern that we had and the reason that
we decided to to pull it off for interim
study was there was concern that the the
Human Rights Commission was just
overburdened and if there was not this
right of removal then all of these cases
are going to end up staying at the Human
Rights Commission and the commission
which is already bogged down is going to
be bogged down even more so so what we
did is we went and we gathered data and
we talked about this in the subcommittee
we looked at the removal rates
basis versus the amount of cases which
are being brought on each month uh by
the Human Rights Commission and when we
looked at that we really found that this
is not a significant burden for them to
be taking on outside of what they
already had so from a legal perspective
SB 296 was sound and from an additional
burden we're talking you know maybe 10
cases a year are being removed from the
Human Rights Commission to Superior
Court and the Human Rights Commission is
actually taking on 20 to 30 cases a
month being docketed so so we really
didn't see any barrier there but the
bigger concern and where we kind of
started to look in a little bit more
detail is just the effectiveness of the
Human Rights Commission itself and the
Human Rights Commission basically
they're in a state right now where
they're kind of in steady state so if
they have 20 or 30 cases coming in a
month they have 20 or 30 cases coming
out but they have this backlog of about
300 cases
that really are just kind of hanging
there and so if you kind of addressed
them on a first in first out basis in
many cases people are going in the
extreme to five years before they get to
a probable cause hearing so the statute
really says that you have two years to
basically to get to that probable cause
resolution so they've been working with
the attorney general's department they
they looked at streamlining certain
elements of the operations we'd ask for
some data around that just to basically
look at from the time that an
investigator is assigned to a case to
the time that probable cause is found
has anything shifted with that we really
weren't able to get at that data but
what we did understand is that turnover
has been a real problem at the Human
Rights Commission stability has been a
real problem at the Human Rights
Commission and so representative you
know Delorenzo looking at basically the
the breadth of the problems that they
had there uh said maybe there would be
some benefit in actually having a
performance audit done of the Human
Rights Commission simpler to that which
had been undertaken uh of the of the
parole board and so I did speak with um
the director of audits and we have a
hearing coming up on November the 10th
for the
um the the board that basically is going
to make the decision as to which
performance audits are taking up so in
addition to you know basically
recommending that the legislation go
forward the three additional
recommendations uh that we we are
looking to to put into the committee
report are number one
um that we push for a performance audit
to be done and we will be going up and
making the case on November 10th for
that
um also that
um the rules of the Human Rights
Commission be brought up to date one of
the things that came about uh as part of
the testimony of the subcommittee is
that they have been operating without
rules for the last five years so
um basically we want to get uh those
brought up to date and approved by gel
car that's something else we want to
push for and and also a review
um as to what resources are needed
basically to allow them to to fulfill
their mandate their resources were cut
back it used to be 10 years ago that um
it was a one-year limit to get the
probable cause when resources were cut
that was moved out to two years but
they're not even meeting that so those
are the three additional recommendations
that
the subcommittee is going to be putting
in the committee report but we are going
to be recommendation the SB 296 as it
was we didn't see any problem with that
and we're going to be recommending that
for future legislation so we hope you'll
representative Smith
thank you Mr chair I think
um we shouldn't let this go by without
first commending representative McLean
who did an incredible amount of work
under difficult circumstances
um not hurting the cats who are on the
committee we were fine but getting the
information
from those people who had access to uh
the data that we needed it was not
easily done
none of us
felt the need to assess blame on anyone
but
I think I can speak fairly for my
colleagues on the subcommittee to say
that we were
shocked and saddened
to realize that there are people in the
state
who because we created a human relations
a Human Rights Commission believes that
there was someone who would pay
attention to their concerns
and in fact that is not what is
happening
um the one most shocking example is that
there came a day when Representatives
came in and said they had been able to
address the backlog and cut it in half
and we were excited about that we
thought that was fabulous that was
terrific we thought did they get more
money did they get more staff they had
asked for more staff did the governor
somehow with all the extra money that's
come in find a way to help help them no
the way they Define cutting the backlog
was they took half of the cases and they
removed them from the investigators
desks and put them in a box someplace
literally and figuratively
um and so now the investigators only had
half as many cases but the people who
were depending upon us us the people of
the state
to address their concerns had no help at
all and
um
uh we all know that
people that that
the Commissioners and other employees
are in difficult position they have to
keep a stiff upper look they have to
keep a smile on their face they're given
x amount of money when they think they
need why they're given a amount of staff
when they think they need B but they
just kind of go on they don't complain
and they think they're being
good sports and responsible to the
people who appointed them
but they are responsible to the people
of the state and this body is not
carrying out their responsibilities so
we really have an obligation
to try to get the data necessary to
change the game and the um performance
audit route is a
a
absolutely solid route here where
trained professionals will go through
this is not a financial audit this is a
a performance audit to look at how they
are organized and how they might be able
to change what they're doing in order to
meet the needs of the states so the tone
that will go in a written statement
will be
um
less emotional
as is appropriate but the reality is
that we have a problem here and we are
obliged to try to address it and so
um I I want to end with the way I began
which is to thank representative McLean
who maintaining an even temper
and
um
a fair and open-minded approach really
helped us through this process so thank
I also would just like to add my thanks
as well to representative McLean to do a
superb job in running the subcommittee
my take is a little bit different with
regard to the performance audit I think
performance audit will be great
but in large part
the commission is operating uh first of
all
just as unbelievable as it is there's a
statute that says that when the
Human Rights Commission gets a case it
needs to complete the case within two
years a statute says that right now
they're completing cases in three years
four years
five years
just totally unacceptable and from my
point of view
a person who was a litigant and knows
that they're going to go the Human
Rights Commission should have a
reasonable expectation that they should
be able to get some type of answer
within a year it just seems reasonable
a year's time but
my concern with the prom performance
audit and I I think it's a great idea
and it'll evaluate it but
so much of what the commission does is
based upon statutes that we've enacted
and put in place with regard to
investigators doing probable cause
assessments and and so forth and I'm
afraid that in the performance audits
they're going to measure
the Human Rights Commission against
the statutes that we put in place where
I think what needs to really change is
the statutes that are in place to make
it more effective and to make it work
better and to serve the people of the of
the state and that is my uh my only
qualification
but I do think the performance audit was
valuable and hopefully get it done but
if it were up to me
if I was still going to be here I'd be
putting in a bill to change the way
probable cause is assessed and the way
things are heard
frankly you you'd have an expectation
that the human right Commissioners are
having hearings they don't have any
hearings they have three or four
hearings a year
uh if you can believe that just
unbelievable anyway uh I'm fully
uh
representative McLean made the motion
and it and it was seconded by
representative naughter
and that is to recommend further
legislation
and I think representative McLean has
already
circulated the report that he intends to
file
okay would you like to call the roll I
would
on the motion to recommend SB 296 for
future legislation
representative McLean yes representative
Sylvia
representative walber boat yes
representative Johnson yes
representative daughter yes
representative murder yes representative
Kelly
representative Andrus yes representative
Smith yes representative wrong yes
representative Horrigan yes
representative Lorenzo yes
representative Chase yes representative
parishion yes representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth
representative page yes representative
Simpson yes Mr chairman yes I have an 18
okay you voted 18-1 to recommend for
Senate Bill 296. Mr chair yes
um I promise I won't take long I do want
to just take uh one quick minute to
respond to your comments almost all of
which I agree with but I have had great
familiarity over many many years
probably too many
um with performance Audits and one of
the important components of a
well-constructed performance audit is a
suggestion based on facts data findings
rather than on emotions of not only
changing rules and regulations and and
processes but also changing the rsas
with a very specifically says say this
RSA has to be changed and um I think you
know to get this issue out of the range
of violence playing in the background
and into a range when some hard
decisions could be made I think the
yes I think that
about concludes our business today is
there anything else yes Mr Mr chair I'd
like to make a statement yep
so uh I think this is going to be the
last time that we uh get together so I
just want to say it really has been an
honor for me to be your your Vice chair
I I've never served in in the capacity
as a vice chair and I was very very
lucky to to have you as chair that you
you really LED this Committee in an
exemplary manner in in the in a period
of increased rank or everywhere
um the debate here was very very
principled but but also very
professional and cordial and you know
that that's getting rare and rarer and
when I heard that you were not going to
run again for me that was a very hard
blow and I'm really going to miss you
especially you know coming right before
that I had a representative Smith as as
a chair so this committee really has
been very very blessed and I'm really
going to miss you sir been here thank
you thank you so much so much oh you
don't need to do that
it's really it was uh it's been my honor
to serve uh the committee it's been my
honor to serve the state first of all
but it's been my honor to be a chair I
was so very fortunate to be given uh
this opportunity and to work with all of
you
you know I the the committee when I look
at the other chairs and I look at the
other committees and what they've gone
through this committee is exemplary in
my in my mind in terms of the way that
we got business done we got a lot of
business done first of all we got a lot
of business done we did it timely we got
it done
and we did it without any any Rancor or
people really being
jerks you know it was
it was uh it was real it was really
really special a lot of a lot of credit
for that goes to representative Smith
who is just you know in terms of
opposite party just perfect to to work
with she was she was terrific too so
and uh but all of you um
uh you you were I
um it was just my pleasure to to work
with all of you and I hope to have
continuing contact with you in some way
foreign
how about by the end of the week how
that's fine
oh
um
and gives you
yeah